is to ride
you'll be all right tonight no one had a
better time at the premiere of Ben
Affleck's new movie air than his wife
Jennifer Lopez
that makes me so happy on Monday Jen
joined her man in La posing on the red
carpet and documenting all the behind
the scenes Deeds posting this clip to
Instagram
[Music]
in the sweet post Jen poses with her man
for the cameras in a neon green dress
with Crystal details there's been
signing autographs for fans and having a
sweet moment with his longtime bestie
and co-star Matt Damon what is the magic
between you and Ben I think it mostly
comes from me I would say no uh I don't
man I you know we've been we've been I
don't know we grew up together uh we see
the world in a really similar way it
makes working together really easy I
feel lucky to have had uh uh you know a
friend and collaborator like that for
this long but the Q cutest moment of all
Jen reaching up and touching Ben's hand
on a movie poster I'm just me and it's
good and it's great yeah safe to say no
one is a bigger fan of Ben than Jen what
can I tell you we're just having a good
time and the feeling is mutual E.T
chatted with Ben at the premiere for his
new film which tells the story of Nike
exec Sonny Vaccaro pursuing Michael
Jordan for a shoe deal when he was just
a rookie in the NBA I find you players
and I feel it this time don't change
that now for real yes who's never set
foot on an NBA court if that's the
literal definition of rookie yeah is it
true that Jennifer helped you with some
of the Fashions to understand the
Fashions of that era and yeah you know I
mean the listen it's brilliant and helps
me in every conceivable way and this
whole process really has been a a
collaboration get a name for it
Air Jordan
seriously maybe it'll grow on me all the
clothes that I wore were that was the
most closely historically documented
stuff I wasn't going to put anything on
I was like we got to make sure there's a
photo of Phil knightware and this is the
80s Nike stuff that was the gear that
was hot in 84 that was the that was how
you did it I mean yeah Captain what do
you think I mean that's that's a good
look it's back you don't know that I
don't know my kids my son rocks it
looked all the time and speaking of a
throwback Goodwill Hunting the flick
that put Matt and Ben on the map and won
them an Oscar just celebrated its 25th
anniversary I think maybe I'll get up
there and I'll knock on the door and you
won't be there
no goodbye and I'll see you later know
nothing
just left
I don't know much but I know that this
is actually where we premiered Goodwill
Hunting like right here
we're gonna go yeah yes you want to see
it in the same theater where you're in
the same theater and now I have my kids
with me it's just crazy it's just nuts
man it's what a life
[Music]
foreign